thank you
[Music]
okay JK mystery moment crap you have to
figure out how the hell this happened
a 19 year old teen in New Mexico
she goes with her mom in the hospital
because she's complaining about back
pains
ends up leaving
the hospital charged with first degree
murder whoa what happened in there I I
guess I'm so sorry timeout look at can
right now he looks like the guy that
that took out that Doug was taking Van
Damme around before
[Laughter]
she has back pain is that what it is
she's yeah she's complaining about back
pain so her mom and her go to the
hospital together something happens in
there in the hospital yeah and then she
leaves being charged with first degree
murder so the murder happened in the
hospital I'm betting was she pregnant
with the mom left can you Transformer or
the the daughter so the first degree is
oh she probably had a baby and then she
had a back pain from the not knowing she
had a baby and then she killed the baby
who died who died sick hold on
how'd you get that
say that again somebody said baby so I
just I just connected in my brain yeah
who said that I don't know
it's like no one said baby yeah well
because
I said figure it out baby
oh that's what I'm guessing because like
you're just coming into the hospital she
doesn't seem like a murderer if she's
just going to the hospital for back pain
you know you don't think murders have
bad herniated discs back pain is
actually pretty common in most
populations murders and non-murderers as
well I don't know because like what was
it an abortion
I think I think it was an abortion in a
state whereas abortion is not allowed so
now it's murder
because how why would she have backup do
pregnant people get back pain no no no
no no no no
Phantom complaints well I want to go
back to my original question who died
yeah you didn't say who died
did you really
yeah you ran with it which is great yeah
yeah I just yeah something I heard yeah
you're right here's here's exactly what
happened it's way more
worse than that
so she I guess
um didn't want to tell her mom she was
pregnant oh Mom didn't know she was
pregnant at all she wasn't the type of
pregnant she wasn't showing right yeah
so she goes in there for the back pain
um when she's in the hospital room like
over at whatever emergency or something
she takes a break goes to the bathroom
oh in the bathroom she has the delivers
the baby and just dumps it in the trash
what yeah
yeah and the baby dies was she no and
then she comes about back out and she's
just like the uh they look in the
bathroom and there's just blood
everywhere because she you know baby in
there and she's covered in blood they're
like what happened
her
she full on had a living full developed
baby
oh she wasn't showing was it she might
have been overweight
she was kind of like slim she just was
it was just a small baby then maybe but
some women some women just don't for
some reason it's like not as visible
because yeah did she like go into labor
and deliver or did she like dig it out
herself she went to labor in the
bathroom delivered it herself and then
just straight to trash Oh my God
straight to trash
reverence for this subject yeah
dang he said straight to trash
dude take the shades off they're turning
into a bad person
you turned into Johnny trans
it I know how I said it can and I said
it with sympathy and condolences
[Music]
um yeah dude that's [__] crazy yeah
so she admitted to doing that um when
she got out she said she um yeah the had
the baby didn't know what to do and then
dang that sucks do you think it was the
parents like she was afraid of her
parents
I specifically Treviso is her last name
what is that sounds like you know
instead of you yeah they might be oh
yeah oh no yeah that's the actual that's
the actual like camera from the hospital
is she a minor or she's not 19. oh she's
explaining to them what yeah she
explains that's that's her like that's
what she looks like oh no she's a kid
she's a kid yeah
yeah yeah I don't think she had pressure
from her parents in some way because
growing up if you know how your parents
are and you feel pressured that's true
like you're more uh what do you call it
uh not encouraged but what's the word
Latino you're more you're more likely to
lie to more likely likely to try to hide
this right but if her parents were more
open and accepting maybe she wouldn't be
afraid on the flip side yeah not to
defend the parents but it could also be
her perception of what her parents
that's what I'm saying yeah sure that's
why I said
parents but
but hey bro her having the conversation
with her mom about it it's pretty bad
they got that all on camera bro but for
her though could you imagine the stress
like it's easier for me to tell my mom I
murdered than it is to tell her I'm
pregnant she literally says yeah but now
you've got both well she probably didn't
think her mom in that video the mom's
just straight up asking her where'd you
put the baby at and she goes it came out
and I put it in the bag and she's like
it went back the trash bags
or anything what I'm curious though is I
don't doubt the article will say is did
she try to clean up the blood
no maybe like and then we're gonna see
this I don't think she I don't think she
was thinking she couldn't even clean up
that much yeah I don't think she thought
it through either and she was bleeding
so like as that's like they had to like
respond to her medically because you
know it doesn't hurt I'm just assuming
in her mind like if she wants she wanted
to hide the fact that she was pregnant
and had the baby I think like I gotta
clean this up and then oh like how am I
gonna clean myself up like oh this is
forget it I'm just gonna walk outside
well that sounds like something like a
kid would do right yeah the mom says
even in that in that uh video she's like
have you watched the news about what the
girls do to their babies and they go to
jail and then the girls just started
crying oh
that's sad yeah and that's what's
happening now she's being charged with
first degree isn't that crazy first
degree that's equal to just like I want
to kill you and stabbing you to death
like and then when she goes to prison
she's gonna be part of the outcast yeah
yeah she won't be like one of the cool
ones that they're afraid of yeah yeah
man crazy thing she probably doesn't
even have the capacity to like murder
somebody no yet she has first degree
murder charges like over this that's
yeah yeah yeah but again like yeah still
a horrible thing to happen
but um it's weird because they said that
um a nurse told the officers that she
had a positive pregnancy test even
though she was she had denied having sex
which could be the case of yeah the
pressure to be like a parent that's a
virgin or something yeah that happens
yeah quite often too of course because
like it could easily just be like the
dad or the mom's like hey you can't ever
have sex or kick you out of the house or
they threatened her or something like
that you know or it could have been a
family member like someone oh no no no
[__] dude oh no which is kind of very
common though yeah which is the crazy
part yeah but then being a murder or
incest but I don't know that she she may
not have thought about the murder part
like I don't know that it connected with
her like I'm killing my I think she just
won the itis like make it like seem like
it's someone else's baby and not mine oh
[__] this is why I think if everyone was
in the fountain pen
kinda though
kind of a hard Sun boy man
an interesting factoid is that
um in recent Years in New Mexico uh
three years ago the same thing happened
whoa was also a girl named Lexi and she
was also 19. no way same exact thing had
the baby didn't didn't tell anybody
threw it in the trash but I was actually
thinking about that where I'm like I
wonder if this is going to be something
that we might see more happen more it
happens a lot actually like yeah eer
like the teacher ER did a couple things
like like this and that was really
important in the 90s which means like
it's been going on for a long time
probably but now there's a media yeah
24-hour news cycle we're probably
hearing about it and then if that's like
if that becomes a trendy thing to like
for the media to do they'll start
digging up like oh no they'll oh that
happened here it happened there yeah
yeah that's true because like you could
understand
obviously what you did was wrong of
course but yeah her age and where she's
coming from
yeah like people are not in their right
mind to make conscious and the right
decision especially what you said where
if like she's a victim of abuse right
then that should yeah it's a totally
different situation how I know this
happens a lot more because in Korea I'm
sure it happens in China too where like
they have the one kid policy and I was
like what 1.2 kids or whatever it may be
but a lot of um they'll just get rid of
the baby
if it's a girl they'll get rid of it or
whatever so in Korea there's one Pastor
he has a thing called Dropbox it's a
literal box where he's like if you don't
want your baby don't leave it abandoned
somewhere put it in the Dropbox and
we'll take care of your baby
yeah right that's initially what it is
the documentary is actually called
Dropbox and so people think oh it's
about that is what it's actually about
that can you imagine oh I want to watch
that
they call it something here with the um
like the mom or parent whoever could
drop the baby off at a fire station
and there's no questions asked wow your
judgment they don't do anything though
yeah and so because it happens so often
yeah why like why kill them yeah so the
crazy thing is is that because she put
the baby in the trash she has to be
charged with tampering of evidence too
you try to hide it yeah yeah because
technically that would be yeah if I was
urgent I would argue no but that's the
means of how she murdered
what if she said that the baby was
already dead when it came out what
they're saying that they did babies I
think they already
determined it wasn't they know I think
it's that's the first I think because
her initial conversation
um they're going up and you know how
they know too there's cameras in the
bathroom but they can't say oh okay I
thought there was just a guy in there
smoking a cigarettes he goes yo this is
[__] up
like what the [__] is going on in here
oh my God those guys are they're in the
walls like like pumping on women they're
always smoking they always get caught
because like the girl goes I smelled
smoke and then I look and there was a
red light like in the hole it's like
what are you doing dude it's like poor
decision-making right sick
mm-hmm